Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
just checking in on you.
What's going on? How are you?
How's things in your world? It's almost
Friday. Ah, today's payday, right?
You're going to get that fucking check.
That fucking Douche is going to come
by with his gold towed socks, right?
Poke his head and your cubicle.
Wait that fucking envelope down, right?
And he's going to be talking to you
and you're not going to hear him. You,
that's going to be sitting there
smile. Or maybe it's a lady,
maybe it's a woman. Maybe she's coming
along with their sensible shoes.
You know, she doesn't have a heel
on it, right? She's taking it back.
You know, tell me what to do with my body.
How come guys don't have to
walk around in high heels?
Why do women have to ruin their feet
and their fucking lower backs? You know,
that's like one of those fucking stories
that like with this stupid ass fucking
election would actually become like a
national story, some dumb shit like that,
you know, complete fucking clickbait
horse shit. Who gives a fuck?
You know, I dunno.
I don't know how people sit down and
watch these conventions my entire life.
I've never been able to get through
one. They are so fucking cringeworthy.
It's so phony. It's so
fake. The fucking smiles,
those maniacal. Hey like
just totally in your head.
You know the candidates at this point,
they have to be completely
fucking exhausted.
They don't want to answer any more
fucking questions and they still have like
another 90 days or this shit that
they have to go through. You know,
you know like when a team
goes to the Super Bowl, right?
I mean you've got the two weeks right
before and they just fucking sit there.
All fucking they report is run out of
questions. Are they just sitting there?
That's two weeks of that shit.
And those players, they go nuts.
Just doing that is fucker Kobo of a guy.
Fuck up my Yana Four. It's
only eight 30 at night.
This is fucking calm over dude
in the clam. They're, they,
they just keep answering
the same fucking questions.
It's gotta be easier for
Trump. You know what I mean?
He just has to just make up some shit.
Listen into Trump,
give his speech is no different than
fucking listen to me do this podcast.
He might as well just be laying
there with his fucking underwear,
his fucking boxes, and just
talking to the American people,
just whatever the fuck he's thinking.
A just says it and then like fucking,
you know, whatever, 20 minutes later
somebody corrects him on Twitter.
That app is be all the time. Every time
I put out a podcast, somebody goes,
hey man, not trying to be a dick,
but just let you know. You know?
Oh, the George Bush thing,
I thought they would just make fun of
George Bush dance and I didn't know he was
doing it at the fucking, it's some,
you know, the police officers funerals,
the memorial service, you know,
I thought Lewis Hamilton was the
upstart driver. They're like, no,
it's actually Nico Rosberg and
every fucking week I do that,
but I'm just some shit head. I'm
not actually running for office. Um,
oh, you're not bill. Thank
you for bringing that up.
We didn't fucking realize
it. Um, so anyways, uh,
uh, you, you truly are a fucking patriot.
If you could sit through those things,
especially this election. Cause uh, I
can't, I can't fucking do it. I can't.
Uh, oh my God. Rudy Giuliani, Yada.
I remember when he fucking
was going off Jesus Christ.
What the fuck was he? What
was going on with him?
I love always voice kept going up.
Like he thought the crowd was going to
go with them and they didn't really,
they kept clapping,
but he kept increasing his energy
and his passion and nothing happened.
At least when Howard Dean
got going crazy when hey,
when he did that thing that
he was reacting to the energy,
at least he was fucking
connected to those people. Rudy,
I don't know what he was doing. Yeah.
I'll tell you the worst fucking image
you could ever picture is Rudy Giuliani,
Bang and Hillary Clinton. I mean,
just imagine that with his fucking that
look at his face when he was screaming
about the cops. And then
Hillary when she, you know,
fucking does that smile where
eyes get all wide. All right.
I'm gonna ruin your fucking
day. Picture her bent over.
Put the fucking eyes all white and that
crazy smile and head behind like I got,
got just fucking banging
away. There you go.
That's on your fucking hard drive
now. You can never erase that.
Um, oh shit. Look at me.
That's another one for the MMP
fucking Photoshop right there.
I look for that one too.
Tomorrow on fucking,
I guess today you listen to it tomorrow
for me on the old fucking Twitter,
Twitter sphere. Um, I had such a
great time this week. You know,
not having to go in the fucking
writer's room has been awesome. Uh,
getting caught up in
all the shit you know,
around the house and all that type of
stuff. It's just, it's just a fucking,
it's only being a comedian
is the greatest fucking job.
It's the greatest fucking job
you could ever fucking have.
Just go on stage and act
like a fucking idiot.
And then afterwards hang out with a
bunch of co comics and then you go home.
Then you wait 24 hours.
[inaudible] we're good.
Apologize for the yarn. And
all of a sudden, um, you know,
I don't know if there's just
something about listening to you,
to my voice that just puts me to sleep.
That's how I got to sleep every night.
You know, that I just start
talking out loud. You know,
I'm saying it in the rain, just saying
20 minutes later I'm, I'm, I'm asleep.
Um, anyway, so Monday night,
as I mentioned last week I did a,
I was going to be doing the
goddamn comedy jam and a,
I busted out the old fucking
John Barnum get up and a,
for the first time ever I played my
Ludwig 71 green sparkle fucking kit,
add my, my drum teacher
swung by the house.
He tuned the fucking things up so
they sounded great and I'm like,
I don't know how they're
gonna sound in the room.
The fucking two year anniversary of Josh
Anna Myers show the Goddamn comedy jam,
which is now become a fucking
pilot on comedy central.
The show is just blown up. So
happy for all those guys. Um,
they had it at the Roxy
down on sunset strip. Now
you got to understand, I am a Phi
came of age in the fucking eighties
a meaning I didn't get laid til the 90s.
Okay.
Um, anyway. Yeah, it will, I'll tell
you it was a rough one for me. Right.
But basically I'm the fucking,
just the bands that were
going on that were, you know,
the sunset strip was total the
fucking hair metal, you know,
the beginning of the metal with
fucking, uh, ready roads, you know,
when he joined Ozzie and
all, all those fucking guys.
And then it went into the hair metal
and then guns and roses pulled it out in
the end and then fucking, uh, who
Kate warrant and all those guys,
all of that shit happened on the
sunset strip out here in fucking la.
And I used to always read about the
whiskey, the Roxy, the Rainbow Rum.
You know, back when I used
to read hit fucking per ray,
anybody used to read hit parade, a
magazine. I fucking loved that magazine.
You know, they used to put all the curse
words in there and everything. I would,
you know what?
I would actually buy one of those
off of fucking Ebay just to read it,
just to see. I'll read, read
about all of those fucking bands.
I knew everybody's name. I knew
the names of every fucking drummer.
I used to watch all the videos that
used to watch the headbangers ball.
Randy Rockman. I used to watch the
top 10 countdown. That was hilarious.
It was either like Janet
Jackson or some hair metal.
I used to think Janet Jackson was,
was was like fucking pussy music.
But these guys will wear lipstick and
had their hair all tee stuff up like some
desperate soccer mom trying to
fall in the last dicker of a life.
I thought that that was
fucking Guy Music, you know?
Okay.
Brittany Fox, I've always brought that
up. The girls school, all that Shit,
you know?
Okay.
Poison. Every rose has its store
and all of that shit. Right.
I got into all, I was into all of that.
Then I started working
in a warehouse and uh,
I worked with these fucking burnouts
that were, they weren't burnouts, they,
they smoked weed, but my world, that
meant you were fucking burnout back then,
you know, cause back then that was
considered was bad. If you smoke weed,
it was illegal. We didn't
realize that you owe,
you actually helped with the
fucking memory back then.
We thought that not your memory,
it helps with Alzheimer's,
whatever the fuck they
claim and who knows.
Okay.
You know, the whole fucking
weed thing is, it's,
it's like the global
warming battle. I just,
it's going to go back and forth and back
and forth and then eventually Bose bags
like myself will finally give and
be like, all right, all right,
you guys were right about
the weed kind of way. People,
all the corporations finally
went like, Oh, you know what, Eh,
global warming is happening and
it is because of us, but you know,
it's too late to fix it now.
Um, so I started working
with these guys and they, uh,
played in a band and like I came
from more of a jock town. Right.
Everybody just fucking played sports
or you just, you know, I don't know,
stood in the corner on a fucking
wall during a party, you know,
it was basically it, those are your only
two options. The town I was in and uh,
these kids were from a couple towns over
and everybody over there and played,
played instruments and these
guys came. I worked with them.
They were playing guitar and they are
playing the shit that was on the radio.
And I, I didn't, I, I didn't do all my
agents. He can fucking get that. Good.
That's amazing. And that's right.
Then when I bought my first drum kit,
I brought a, I was 20 years old when
I started playing fucking drums.
I had done everything late in
life. I was always fucking,
I had day late in a fucking
dollar short. Right. And um,
I had this,
I bought a five piece Slingerland
kit at the time it was,
I bought it in 1988 I think.
And it was like 10 years old.
It was all bottom sizes, but it
was more like the five ply ones.
It wasn't the three
ply shelves. So it was,
they were already starting to fucking
make them too heavy. But uh, it was uh,
black and it had a, Oh God, I
can't remember the fucking sizes.
It was Whoa, it had an 18 inch
floor, Tom, a 24 inch kick.
And then what the fuck was the
rack? I think it was like a 13.
It was really weird sizes.
And then later I ended up,
I went down to l Drew's shop
in Woonsocket, Rhode Island.
I believe that's where it was.
And I found a 16 inch floor Tom,
which was fucking unbelievable.
That matched my kit. Even
the badges said Niles,
Chicago, Niles, Illinois. Sorry. Um,
and
you know, there was no fucking
Ebay back then. I didn't know.
There was no way to track down all of
this shit that people had lying around the
house. I just went into that place.
They had all these old drums and they
happen to have that and I fucking bought
that thing. I was nine
by 13, 10 by 14, 13,
14 in 18 and a 24 kick. So
then I got the six 16 inch.
So now I had um, I had a six piece kit,
which I thought was the shit.
And then I got some Rodo toms put them
on the other side of the high hat cause I
was watching Alex van Halen cause it
was all about having the biggest fucking
kits you could possibly have.
Okay.
And then along came guns and roses and a
guy named Steven Adler and he showed up
with a little four piece
kit, right rack, Tom floor,
Tom and his fucking ride sitting
in between the two, which was just,
it was the shit.
And he got more music out of that than
half these fucking guys with double bass
drum kicks. Fucking two toms above
each base drama to floor toms. Right.
And um, that just
completely changed my life.
So long story short, I used to always
read up on all that. I try to do all,
try to figure out how to spin
the sticks, all of that shit.
And back in the day I could do was watch
MTV and try to figure this shit out or
you just listen to the records.
And we added even better
than the kids in the 70s,
cause there was no fucking
MTV. Maybe he caught him on a,
I don't know Dick Clark fucking
show with some shit. So,
but I'll use to have it
here about was, you know,
if you wanted to fucking make it in
rock music back then you had to be down
there. So here we are fucking
almost Jesus Christ. 30 years later
I finally get to fucking go down there
on a Monday night and I got to play drums
at the Roxy. It was fucking incredible.
And I sucked when we practice,
like on Thursday, I sucked on Sunday and
then during soundcheck I was only okay.
And I was like, God damn it. I had
all these friends coming down ago.
Wouldn't you fucking know?
Cause you know I hadn't played and
played since March and I'm a comedian,
so I already sucked even
when I was playing. And, uh,
so went out and did my set dressed as
fucking bottom and I sat down behind the
kit. I don't know what happened.
I just took it, I don't know,
just kind of fuck it right.
And I ended up playing for me.
I played great. I had the most fun. I
was the loosest that I've ever been at a,
it was fucking hilarious of
playing the song. And uh,
Dave Cushner who, uh,
does the music for a f is for family
and also was in velvet revolver.
He was playing the song too
when he always, you know,
fucks around and shit makes me laugh.
So I had this stupid fake mustache glued
to my upper lip and he was making me
laugh and I knew I couldn't
smile. It was going to come off.
So then half of it was fucking flap and
he started laughing and then the thing
literally floated off my face and we
only halfway through the first song and
then I had this stupid bandanna
around the fucking John Bonam wig.
That thing came off. Then
the hair was in my face.
I looked like the chick from the ring
and my sunglasses started fogging up.
So it's funny, I was playing,
I was on a green sparkled kid dressed
as John Bonam and we were playing ac DC.
None of it made sense. So of
course it was, you know, working
because you know, you just fucking
around. So then we did highway to hell.
And in the end that was the encore. We
did highway to hell. And then everybody,
we bringing everybody out per crusher, um,
who fucking destroyed. He opened,
he did a red hot chili
peppers, give it away now.
And not only did he come
out just wearing the sock,
he talked to everybody in
the band into doing that. Um,
I was not out there for that. And,
uh, then Margaret show went up,
she fucking killed it. Uh,
Harlan Williams saying eyes without
a face. He fucking killed it. And,
uh,
then Ron white went up and sang
Leonard skittered give me three steps.
I hope somebody took video with this
shit. So I had to follow all of that.
And uh, fortunately was a great
crowd. And, uh, so anyway,
so in the end they brought everybody
out to sing highway to hell.
And they kept me on drums. By then
my hair is, that wig is in the face.
I can't see through
the fucking sunglasses.
And in the end they just wanted me to
keep doing like the symbol wash thing as
the introduced everybody, you know,
another round of applause for everybody.
And I forgot and I couldn't see.
So I kind of stopped playing
and I kept hearing the guitars.
It was a cluster fuck, but
it was hilarious. And, uh,
I want to thank everybody
that came out and, um,
I have to tell you that's
the best sounding fucking
drum kit I've ever played in
my life. 26 inch bass drum.
And the way my teacher,
uh, tuned it up and the way they miked
it up, it sounded fucking unbelievable.
And what I loved was everyone in the band
was saying how great the fucking kits
sounded. And, uh, I dunno,
I have to figure out, I swear to God,
I have to figure out a place where I
can just set that fucking thing up.
That's the goal. That's what
sucks about having a fucking,
there's no place to play. When you
play drums, you have a fucking guitar,
you can turn down your ramp. There's
no way to do it. And you know,
as fun as those electronic kits are, I
don't have just talking drums on this,
but who gives a shit? I barely
ever talk this much about drums.
They got these drums. Like if
you live in an apartment, right?
The way it go if you still want to
play is you buy a set of v drums.
All right? Those are the best electronic
drums as far as I'm concerned,
that are out there. You buy that mid
level one, so it's not that much money.
There's always ones used on Ebay.
And then what I used to do was I
would put foam down on the floor,
then just build the little two by fours
and simply apply would just build a
little drum riser. Okay.
Put carpet on that foam and then
another layer of carpet. Okay.
And then you put the drums on top of that.
And then what you do is you go
downstairs and you meet your neighbor.
You tell him, hey, I play
drums. I'll only play during,
this is what I used to do. I say, I'm,
I'm stand up. I work nights. All right,
I'll play during the day. Only Monday
through Friday if I'm going to play,
I play during the day.
If for whatever reason,
if you're ever home during those
times, here's my phone number,
just call this number and I will
immediately stop. I mean, that's,
that's the best you could fucking do.
I told this story before and then
the guy ended up being a cunt,
you know,
one time out of the 5,000 times I played,
he ended up being home sick or some shit
or he had a vacation and he called up,
alright, I pick up the phone. I'm
like, hello. And he just goes,
can you knock it off like
right out of the fucking gate?
Okay.
And I was like, all right,
Jesus, quite, I was younger then.
Now it would've been like, dude, hey.
Yeah, you don't fucking say that.
Like you said it to me 50 fucking
times. You can't, I gave you my number.
I couldn't be any nicer.
All right, I'm gonna stop,
but go fuck yourself and please call
me again if I bug you and I would have
laughed at him and I would have
left it at that. But anyways, um,
okay.
Three Ali is, you're not playing
drums if you're on an electronic kit.
I can't explain it. It's weird because
if you're playing an electric guitar,
you're really playing guitar,
but there's just something about those
electronic drums. I Dunno, I think,
I think most dramas would agree with
me. This is something that you play.
You sit down on electronic
drums and you're like, I,
how have I not fucking toward the world
is one of the greatest drummers of all
time. This sounds fun. I sound
incredible on this fucking thing.
And then what happens is then
you sit down, bind a real kit,
and you actually have to
make the sound happen.
Rather than just fucking hitting somewhere
on the pad and getting a nice snare
sound or fucking bass drum. Then all
of a sudden you get on a real kit,
you're like, oh, that's
right. That's right.
I'm not one of the greatest dramas
of all time. It's the exact opposite.
I'm one of the worst fucking
drummers that ever fucking lived.
This is an embarrassment.
I should be on an electronic kit cause
at least those you can turn down. Um,
so anyways, um,
okay.
I can't stop thinking of how fucking
unbelievable those fucking drum sounded.
I'll do. They sounded so
fucking good in, in between.
We played if you want blood and then
when they will bring in everybody out.
Like I was just, I still had
to keep playing them. They
sounded so fucking good.
Play that beginning beats it in my time.
A dying back bet to do
[inaudible] they just founded. Oh,
they sounded fucking amazing.
That's killing me. I swear to God.
I swear to God. Why the fuck did
I build a gym out of my well,
cause I didn't want to be a
fat fuck. That'd be hilarious.
If I built a drum room instead
and I put those things out there,
nobody could hear it.
And then I didn't work out and
I got fat and I started looking.
You ever see those awful pictures of
John Bonam when he had the fucking wife
Beater on Jesus Christ and he's
like 27 years old back then?
Like people just looked so
fucking old. I don't know what,
I don't know what was going
on back in the day. You know,
like they just showed that fucking
lunatic, that fucking lunatic.
John Hinckley who shot Ronald
Reagan Shut Brady in the head,
totally altered that guy's life. Quality
of life. Forget me fucking people.
He shut. They just let that
guy out. And Oh, by the way,
he was obsessed with Jodie foster cause
he kept watching her in taxi and I,
yeah, I think she was like 13 years
old in that fuck it thing. Yeah,
let's let that guy out that
that's a good thing to do.
Jesus fucking Christ, the guy's
been in there for 35 fucking years.
What's he gonna do?
So you're going to go work or one
of those yogurt shops. I mean, what,
what exactly is
the guy has no fucking resume,
you know, Dick, imagine
that guy's fucking resume. What it
must be like. Just be like, alright,
he plug Mr Ankle. He,
let's see here. And uh,
see he was 25 when he got
arrested. 1980, 81. Let's see.
So let's just say, let's say he was a
go getter. He got his first job at 16,
so he would've had nine years on his
resume. That takes us back to about,
uh, about 1972. Let's see, in 1972, a,
you had a job stocking
shelves in a grocery store.
He did that for a couple of years. Uh,
you got a job at a bowling alley.
It's gonna be all 70 shit, right?
It, uh, then you shot
the president, right?
And then there's a a,
was it a 35 year gap?
Okay. Shout the president. 1981.
And now you, uh, you want
to work here at staples.
Tell you what, we're going
to put this in the bin.
I'm going to have a manager look at it.
I want to thank you for coming in and,
no, no, no, no. There's no
reason to contact us. We'll, uh,
we'll get back to you as soon as
we can. I don't understand that.
This is what I think they should do.
They should fucking transfer Hinkley to
wherever the fuck John Charlie Manson
is. All right.
Then you stick them in side by side
cells and then they just host the reality
show. You don't,
neither one of them has seen the
outside world for roughly the same time.
Whatever. Charlie Manson's got like
10, 12 years on it. But at that point,
once you're up to 35 fucking years, you
know, Oh, I've been in for 47 years. It,
that doesn't fucking
make a difference. Right.
Even you just have just fucking
talk locally, locally. No,
just have them talk about
just, you know, random shit.
You just show him a video. Give him a
little glimpse of the outside world. Hey,
uh, Charlie Manson, what'd you think
about lady Gaga has meat dress, you know,
but whatever the fuck's going on in
the world, I don't know. All right.
That's a bad idea.
Hmm.
Oh, is it? Is that a good reality show?
We've taken some of the most infamous
criminals of the past 50 years,
stuck them all in a circle of cells and
your eyes won't believe what happens
next. Um,
you know what's funny is I could probably
get to at least the second level of
pitching that show strong interest before
the whole thing fell apart and they
realized like, well, wait a minute.
How the fuck are we going to get
transferred this guy to the other prison?
I the overhead's too
high, you know? All right.
There's always a moment with every podcast
where it goes off the fucking rails.
And I'm going to go out on a limb
and say, it's this moment right here.
This is the moment right
now where I wonder,
what the fuck am I going
to talk about next? Um,
do that guy 60 fucking years old now.
He spent from 25 to years old in a
fucking nuthouse and they're gonna,
they're gonna let 'em out now.
Well, fucking job. Cree
is a 60 year old. Yeah,
you got any yard computer skills?
You sit in there. What are those?
I mean those giant things
from the $6 million man now.
Now they're like [inaudible] they weigh
like fucking three pounds now. You know,
he probably thinks it's a plastic book.
Um, I don't know what they said. They're
gonna fucking try to monitor this guy.
What the fuck is wrong with it?
I just, I don't understand it.
Okay.
I don't understand that.
Like it isn't a thing too.
If you're going to fucking
give a guy 35 fucking years,
just put him out of his
fucking misery. Right.
Wow. What would you rather do? Would
you rather spend 30 years in a 35 years?
25 to 60 no one had 60 you get out or
they can give you the old right there.
Fred, you know, your choice.
I think I'd choose a fire in squad if I
had to go out fucking get electrocuted,
you know,
or have you put me down like some old
collie with a little fucking injection.
I don't want that shit. Who
would want that? I don't
just fucking have me in front
of a firing squad. Right.
Hey did we not the face just fucking
center mass. Boom. Done over. All right.
Here we go. Did I mention,
I can't remember cause I started this
podcast a couple of times here that I
mentioned. I got some new
dates coming up. Okay.
I've mentioned the European dates.
I've got some new dates coming up that
are going on sale this Friday and I'm
very excited about this
because these are the shows.
These are the shows that I'm doing as I'm
getting ready to do my fifth hour long
standup special. Very proud of that.
My five year five special anniversary.
Okay, here we go. I've got to make
update coming up. Coming up. Hey,
it's coming up. Um, this is in Huntington,
New York at the paramount theater.
Wednesday, September 7th is a
7:00 PM and a 10:00 PM show.
This is the makeup show for
that show that I canceled, uh,
due to weather out on long
island, um, earlier this year,
back in January, I believe.
I'm finally making that one up.
And then on September 8th, I'm in, uh, at
the Charleston Galley Yard
Center in Charleston, South
Carolina. September 10th.
I'm in North Fork, Virginia
at Chrysler Hall. Uh,
September 11th, Sunday I'm
in Richmond, I'm in Richmond,
Virginia at the Altria theater. And then,
um, let's see, the next weekend I'm
swimming with great white sharks.
I'll tell you about that later.
Uh, oh Jesus. Getting over a fear.
Stupid Thursday, September
29th I'm in Madison,
Wisconsin at the Orpheum
theater. October 1st.
Holy fucking shit. Okay.
Does that say all my Honda Brasco it's
just gonna be my triumphant return to,
to know I have not been
in Nebraska since. Okay.
Since I was always doing
college kicks. I don't,
I can't remember the last time I
was there. The Orpheum theater.
Okay. That's going down
on October 1st all right.
This is when we're getting
down to crunch time.
We're getting closer to the special
Thursday, October 6th. I'm in Atlanta,
Georgia at the Fox theater.
Friday I talk October 7th.
I'm in Gainesville, Florida. All right.
What the fuck would a goddamn Yankee
like me be doing down in Gainesville,
Florida and Friday, October 7th. Well,
I'll tell you what, boy, I tell you what.
Okay.
That's because on October 8th the LSU
Tigers are playing the Florida gators down
there on the swamp. I cannot
fucking wait to go to that game. Uh,
I love both those programs. And A,
I've always been a dream of mine as a
sports fan to always to go into that
stadium before they tear it down and
gave him some new flashy new one that
fucking looks like everybody else's.
I just want to see the layout,
like that whole section of that weird
wall where it just says the swamp.
Like what the, there was that one that
was multipurpose stadiums that they,
they used to be able to spin it around
and to make it a baseball diamond.
And then after a while it just
broke and they said, fuck it.
It's a football field. I have no
idea. But I want to go see that.
A very unique looking stadium and
their fans are fucking awesome.
And a as it's SCC football.
And then from a Saturday,
October 15th to Thursday,
October 20th I'm going to be in
Washington DC at the national theater.
Now what's great about that is, uh,
I'll be doing probably a couple shows at
night. Oh, it's, yeah. Theater. Oh No,
actually no. Maybe I'll
just be doing one tonight.
I don't know when I'm gonna be doing,
but, um, that's the crunch time.
I'm working every single Saturday, Sunday,
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
doing a little residency I believe is
what they call before I get ready to do my
special. And um, I never
write my shit down.
And this time is a few things that I think
I'm actually going to try writing out
and then improving on it and just seeing
how it goes on this special just to try
something different. You know,
I'm always trying to do
something a little different.
Can't be giving you the same old bill
every fucking special. Right. So, uh,
I'm very excited about that. Uh,
I'm ridiculously excited about the,
uh, European tour coming up,
not excited about the long flight and um,
you know, the lovely Nia will not be
going with me to those fucking shows.
I'm just doing it cause it's a thrash.
I mean it's all right for me cause I get
that they at the higher doing the show,
but she's just going to be
getting fucking, hey, you
like this city. All right,
here's another one. You
know, every fucking day.
I think that would get a
little old. But uh, so any who,
um, I think that's it, right?
Is that my little half hour?
Did I do my little fucking pennants
for the week here? Huh? Oh,
I'm seven seconds underneath. Um,
thank you to everybody. Once again,
they came out to the goddamn
comedy jam and thank you to Josh,
Anna Myers and all those guys for
letting me get to play at the Roxy dude
dressed as John Bond and plaintiff's
71 Ludwig wicked me fucking,
you know what I mean? That's,
that's some shit some day when I'm fucking
old and I'm staring at the wall still
drinking. Of course I'm going
out like Peter O'Toole, right?
Still fucking drinking.
I'm just going to have the greatest
smile on my face just thinking about shit
like that. Like I fucking did
that. That was so much fucking fun.
And, uh, it was just great. I will do
that show as long as they fucking do it.
And, uh, so that's it.
And, um, yeah, that's it.
Now I'm off to Ireland.
Next time I talked to you.
I don't know where I'm going to be. I
don't know where I'm going to leave,
Ilana. I think I'm
going to be over in, uh,
I think I'll have already done the three
dates in Ireland. Maybe, or maybe not.
I don't know.
All I know is I think I drive
from Bristol to Manchester,
England. And if I have time,
I have to pay my respects at John Bottom's
grave and I have to do it in a row.
I going to do it. No fucking
selfie. None of that bullshit.
Uh, you know, tried to do in a classy
fucking way. You know what I mean?
I always remember, cause I went to Elvis's
house one time and I just felt bad.
I went there to actually laugh,
like, oh, get a bit out of this.
And I went to his house,
Graceland, and I just felt bad.
I just felt like I was intruding
on the guy's personal life and uh,
uh,
if they had like a gift shop across the
street with like Elvis cuckoo clocks,
like decades,
one of the most exploited fucking
entertainers of all fucking time.
I mean the guy's been dead for almost
40 years to still make money off his
fucking image. Um, then the end,
you walk by his grave and the back,
it's just like a bunch of people
just walking by and Yammer and,
and saying dumb shit and they're just to
sound a fucking flip flops and poverty
just walking by. It was
just bad. It's like, well,
what are we doing here? What are we
doing? Are there like an Elvis head?
The three TVs,
cause at least the lock to watch all
the fucking games and the TVs are all
fucking out of date.
But you know something,
when I went in there into his house,
I really saw how fucking like, yeah,
this must've been the only place that
this guy could go to escape how famous he
was.
And it must've been really nice for him
to be here and just be able to chill and
relax.
And it's just really fucking ironic that
this place that was so peaceful for him
is that we're all traipsing through it
all trying to stretch our heads and look
up to the fucking the upstairs.
So maybe you can see the toilet that
he fucking collapsed from, you know,
it's really bad. All right. I
guess I'm going to end on that.
All right.
And I commend anybody who really
honestly sits there and watches these
Republican and Democratic national
conventions at this point.
If you can actually sit through
there. I didn't watch it, but did, uh,
did the fucking guy there,
um,
Bernie Sanders, did he, did he
just completely flip flop and Endorse
Hillary? Is that what he did? I mean,
just how can I just not think.
I just don't understand is how you can
sit there watching somebody in a debate
trashing somebody and trashing them and
trash from trash them saying why they
think they're going to be awful.
And then when the person they say
is going to be awful beats them,
they then just do a fucking
one 80. It'd be like,
I think there's person that I said sucked
is going to make a great president and
as my full endorsement.
Um,
so anyways. All right. That's it.
I'm done. Yap. And uh, that's it.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm still fucking buzzing off
that fucking show Monday night.
I still can't believe I got to fucking
do that. So cool. So fucking cool. Uh,
that's it. All right. Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend. You're constant.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Alright. Fucked up. I got a couple of
reads I got to do here. I didn't see him.
All right. Club Gabby, daddy old
Geraint um, innovative concept.
I'm going to, I'm going
to pick this copy here.
Have you ever been in the wine
aisle at your local store?
Just staring at the massive selection of
wine with no idea which bottle of booze
to choose from.
Most of us go with the bottle that has
the best looking label and hope that it's
going to be good. Well,
the days of playing Russian roulette
with your wine selections are all
because the club Debbie looking out for
the terrorist is a revolutionary new
wine club that takes the
class, the guesswork, sorry,
out of choosing your wine,
they have a simple six question Palette
quiz that will match you with delicious
high quality wine. You
are guaranteed to love.
The best part is that it clipped Debbie
Plains with Dick Cheney will actually
ship your wine straight to your door.
No more going to this store and
being lost in the wine aisle.
Love wine. We've got the perfect
wine for you at club Denny and said,
Donald Brownsville club Debbie is a
revolutionary wine club that delivers high
quality wine straight to your door.
They partner with the innovative wine
makers from all other all over the world
to produce a wide variety of small lot
handcrafted wines for their members with
club Debbie sit down and try to cue them
a day. I'm going to go get all my pups.
Weapons of mass destruction.
You have the freedom to pick up and
choose the types of wine and the number of
bottles you receive each month.
The best part is they offer a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee on every
single bottle bottles. Start drinking
personalized wine selection today.
Try Club Debbie. I'm going to dance.
I don't care if it's a field girl. Um,
all right, that's it. Now, where
the fuck do people go get this?
Is there anything here? I don't know. $20.
Okay. Right code right now. Uh,
club w was offering listeners $20 off
your first order when you go to club
Debbie at.com/burr and
it gets even better. Uh,
I know you hate paying for shipping and
all that Shit, so act so club Debbie.
Well, I'm going to pass him.
I in gonna knock with her.
We'll actually pay for your shipping on
orders of four bottles and more so it
takes something off your
to do list. Join club
w.com/burr to get $20 off
your first order. Now.
That's [inaudible] dot
com slash burr. All right,
last one. Uh, no. Let
me just hit stop here.
All right. What is it about buying a
mattress that leaves you feeling violated?
Um, is it the pushy people,
the fake president's Day sale,
or the fact that you know, you regret
what you bought as soon as you walk,
you do the walk of shame
out of the mattress store.
Those days are, oh, thanks.
He Helix sleep where you
can buy a mattress online,
customized for you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands.
Thousands of fuck pays
$1,000 for a mattress. Jesus.
Some high quality whore right
there. Go to helix.com first answer,
a few simple questions. And Helix Curry.
Alex creates your custom sleep profile
of build you the perfect mattress.
The result, our customers
report 30% improvement in
their overall quality sleep.
You're your mattress,
little arrive at your door and a
welder week shipping is 100% free. Uh,
you have a hundred nights to try
it out. If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free,
grow and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked. It's like it
never happened. Yeah. Jesus. Uh,
if you do love the new Hellickson
mattress, keep it and your dignity.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine
to Forbes to talking about helix sleep.
Go to helix, sleep.com/burn and get
$50 off your order. That's heavily
sleep.com/bro Helix sleep.com/ [inaudible]
do
rather well. When my, my
eyes were watching news,
they closed and I was still listening
for when my hand was holding
hers, she whispered words
bouncing around the
room. [inaudible] spoke
and I was bouncing around the room.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's going on? This is bill bar,
the Monday morning podcast and this
is the third attempt at trying to be
remotely amusing on this thing. Cause A,
I've been on vacation last week and
I'm too unhappy and I'm too relaxed.
I had a great time down
Nantucket, one of the, uh,
one of the widest places on the
planet. It's not that what's funny,
I just literally had to pause when
I said one of the, what is things?
Because someone of color was coming by
and for some reason I thought that it was
going to be viewed as racist. Like
I was actually going like, yeah,
it was really white. It was
awesome. It was actually,
it was so white. I believe my level
of whiteness was actually offensive,
if you can believe it.
And uh, yeah, very, uh,
I can't explain the
welfare. It's, I don't know,
I was staying out in Sconsin, which is
even more snooty than on Nantucket. But,
uh, if you ever get out there
is a little a tip I'll give you,
take a trip of the, a
fucking brewery out there.
The hell's the name of it.
Uh, Cisco, Cisco Brewers,
they make their own beer, wine
and vodka out there and uh,
go on their website. If you're a big
vodka drinker, cisco.com I believe,
but just look up Cisco Brewer's CIS,
c o I'm telling you, this shit
is smoother than greatness. It's,
it's unbelievable. I guess
the island sits on an aquifer.
The amount of times people
told me that in the last week,
it's just some point it
would come up. Uh, you know,
this island sits on an aqua
for and like you, I was like,
what the fuck is an aquifer? I was
on vacation so the fuck wasn't there.
It was more like, oh, and what
might an aquifer be? Evidently, uh,
you know, I don't know what it is.
I was going to go on the Internet
and I was going to look it up,
but as far as I could tell from the drunk
people in their boat shoes and their
tiger woods shorts,
they was saying that a Nantucket was
formed from a glacier and somehow,
uh,
I don't know what sits on fresh water
and the water trickles under all kinds of
bedrock and shipped from Massachusetts
and ship that just really killed the
cleanest of the water. It fucking
comes from Massachusetts and shit.
It's like really fucking clear. But yeah,
it goes right underneath the ocean
and I guess it comes right up and a,
that's how they make their
pod could taste so good.
I learned that the trick that all my
life when I had no idea that the cleaner
the water, the smoother and more
pure euro your heart stuff is.
So maybe that's why all those hillbillies
and they can moonshine up in the
Appalachian trail. You know,
you, they talked to somebody,
not 10 people I know who,
who've walked the Appalachian trail
and somehow got Lyme disease and a,
you know, I'm all up for an adventure.
But when you get like a disease that
they did an episode about on little house
on the prairie, you know what I
mean? Basically some 1800 shit,
you know what I mean? You get a,
it's all looked the other way.
I mean we've all uh, put the gun to
my head, you know what I'm saying?
That's a modern disease. But
you get like typhoid fever
or the plague. I'll say
what's fucked up man.
I was reading this book on the population
and uh, I think I talked about this.
I can't,
I can't remember last week I was doing
podcast from a bathroom in this cabin I
was staying at,
cause it's the only place I could get
some sort of cell phone service, but uh,
to reading this book about population
and basically I think medicine
is what really fucked us over.
A lot of people think it's dumb people
fucking and creating more people.
That's really caused the
population problem, but it isn't.
It's smart people giving dumb people
penicillin that has caused the population
explosion. And A, I can't
stress to you enough,
having traveled as much as I had truly.
How many people need to die
in an avalanche for us to
ever save the polar bears?
I know the fuck I'm talking about going
to Goddamn Sunburn on my brain here.
All right. Now if you're new to my page,
man, I got a big thing coming up here.
Uh, I was saying last week my special
was coming out on August 23rd,
they just moved the day by my own one
hour stand up special coming out on comedy
central on August 31st all right.
And it's called, why do I do this?
And it's actually coming on
after one of Dane pokes specials,
which is great because he
has like 9 million fans.
So if a third of them hang around
it's going to be a great thing for me.
Um, yeah, August 31st and
this week my CD comes out,
we'll be in stores, uh, of the same name.
It's basically a CD of the
specialists coming out on 31st.
Then in September the DVD will be coming
out. So look for all that and stores.
I'll have more information this week
and I'll be putting something up on my
website as far as, uh, they
give you all that information.
But let's get down to the podcast
questions cause my flight's going to be
leaving here soon. My flight
to Charlotte and then on to La.
I don't know why I got the connecting
flights. Seemed like a good idea.
Fucking stupid. All right.
Uh, Bill with all, uh,
the latest postings. What the fuck did
my laptop just do? What are you doing?
Hello? Hang on.
You know that when you try to click on
something and then it selects it and then
just start to going 90 miles an
hour down the page. All right, bill,
with all this posting of late have a
spontaneous crowd members heckles and
interruptions. It's
getting me wonder about,
wondering about a couple of things
I butchered reading that question.
They're basically saying in the last month
I put a couple of postings on youtube
and on my mind space page of people
yelling out random shit during my shows.
Uh, her question is, uh,
you've seen or his question,
I don't know who sent this.
You seem to be pretty nice
generally to these people,
even if they're being a dick,
but I'm sure that's always,
that's not always the case.
Have you ever offended someone to the
point of them trying to fight you or made
someone cry or something
else really awkward? Um,
actually, you know what, the two people
heckling me, the lady going, thank you.
And the guy who was in the
crowd who was blind, neither.
Neither one of them will be in malicious,
which is why I wasn't being malicious
back to them. You know what I mean?
That's kind of how I work at.
If someone's being a dick to me,
I become a nuclear Dec to them
cause you have to out get them.
You know what I'm saying?
It's weird. You gotta be,
you gotta go 10 times meter than they're
ever going to go. You know what I mean?
It's like that untouchables. They
bring a knife, you bring a gun,
you know they make funny you fucking pen.
You talk about their mother's
vagina cancer or something.
I know it's disgusting, right. But
you know, I don't make the rules.
That's how it works. All right? You
want to change the stand up world.
You go do the late show.
You go do the third show,
Saturday night in the
middle of fucking nowhere.
And you tell me that vaginal cancer does
not seem like a viable means of self
defense. I'm not wishing
that on anybody, but, uh,
I'm not above bringing it up and
wishing it on a crowd number.
I Dunno. And it's hypothetical mother.
All right. That was brutal. Um, anyways,
have you ever offended someone to the
point of them trying to fight you? Uh,
yeah. I had one girl chased me
around the state one time and uh,
I didn't know what to do, you know,
cause she was abroad and if I
hit her I'm going to go to jail,
which is a funny thing about
that. You know what I mean?
It's like they get up there and they've
got a glass and they want to smash it
over your head. You know,
I'm not trying to be a dick,
but at the end of the day that is,
you know, the average woman is,
weighs over a hundred pounds, you
know, upwards of 150 you know,
the average broad out there, you
know, they got some a d titties,
they might be pushing one 60, who knows,
right? You start swinging a glass.
You know, I never took a physics class,
but you can really fuck somebody up.
But for some reason because they
have a vagina cancer free of course.
Um, all of a sudden now I have
to stand there. There's really,
there's really no way to get out
of it without looking like a tool.
Either stand there and you let some
girls smash you over the head and be,
you run away and you look
like the biggest fag ever.
Or see you blast them in
the face and uh, you know,
then you look like, you know, you look
like a wife beater rather than no.
There was another adult who
they, rational brain who was,
you had a glass which is considered a a
is that attempted murder if you smash it
, I know if you smash a bottle over,
somebody said that's assault
with a deadly weapon.
I do know that as is if you bumped
into somebody with your car,
I learned that how the one, I'll
tell you that story here in a minute.
Basically what happens is lady came up
on stage so I didn't know what the fuck
to do. So I just picked up the mic. Stan
and I put it between her and myself,
sort of alligator armed.
It didn't have an extended way out
cause I would seem too hostile.
So I kind of had it, you know,
I didn't want to have it up against me
because that would defeat the purpose.
So I kind of had to halfway, you know,
so it was like I was extending an olive
branch in a way and I basically backed
up in a circle and she was so
drunk. She kept following me until a
place. She, I think she got tired. It
was danger fields where it happened.
And uh,
of course there's no security there so
they probably just sitting there laughing
in their oceans 11 waste cloak
from waist length, red coats,
math, fucking, why am I even trying
to be funny here on to fun to relax.
I'll be funny next week.
I already forgot the story that I
told you I was going to tell you.
Jesus Christ. Let me go back
here a second. What the fuck was,
I was talking about being on stage,
somebody chasing you. Oh, the
car thing. But that's right.
What time? I was in a car. Right. And
that was driving. Isn't that unbelievable?
Yeah. I know. I'm living an amazing
life driving down the street and uh,
I put on my left directional,
it's getting to the left lane.
So there's this lady in the left lane,
but there's enough room for me to get in.
But she does the conti thing.
She stomps on the gas. Right. So,
you know, trying not to let me in, you
know what I mean? Then drives, you know,
she basically cut me off. She doesn't
let me until I get behind her,
I'd be better. So she beats at me. So
I'm like, what the fuck? I'm right.
You cut me off. I be back at
her. And then she just snapped.
She just slammed on the horn and held
it all the way up to this red light,
which was like a football field
away. She just went like, eh.
So like a half a mile staring at me.
I could see her VDI staring
at me in the rear view mirror,
came all the way up to
the red light, my hand.
And the second she stopped,
I just beat real quick.
I went to sleep just to piss her off
just so I'd get it last, you know,
the next thing you know, I just see her
reverse lights come on and she fucking,
uh, she backed into the front of
my car really lightly and I'm like,
what the fuck is this girl doing?
And then I see a reaching into the
glove box and I was like, oh my God,
she's got a gun. And there was somebody
behind me so I couldn't get out.
And Uncle Eddie, I panicked.
I didn't know what to do.
So she jumps out of the car and you know,
I rolled down my window like a
crack because I'm so scared. Right.
You know this, this psycho lady.
I'm like, what's your problem? She,
she ended up having a pad and a piece
of paper and she wrote down my license
plate number. Then she jumped
in the car and she drove away.
Unfortunately somebody saw it and they
said, hey, was that a friend of yours?
Cause that's how lightly she hit me.
I said, no, that was some psycho.
And the person gave me their
business card, which I kept.
So because I'm a fucking Moron, oh,
I just completely forgotten about it.
And next thing you know, I'm on the road
and all of a sudden I get a phone call.
Yes. Hello.
This is a offices Shepard calling
from the Elsa Gunda police department
investigating a, a hit and run
possible assault with a deadly weapon.
Basically what she did was she backed
her car into my car and then said I
rear-ended her. Um, but I had the business
card so I was able to get out of it.
And uh, you know, who knows, I don't
know what would have happened. You know,
I could've gone to jail and uh,
someone that tried to rape me and then
I'd have to kill him and then I'd be like
Tom Selleck and that
really bad movie, you know,
that's why I like Shawshank redemption.
That's the only one
with the dude actually.
They show what would happen if an
accountant goes to jail. You know,
he doesn't start with doing weights
and somehow take over the jail. Now,
you know what happens? He gets fucking
raped and he gets raped for years.
And that's why you always want
to have a fucking alibi, okay?
Especially if you have a bad marriage.
If you're going through a tough time,
whenever you go out, always make sure
you've got a friend with you, okay?
Because if you don't,
someday when someone does you the favor
of lacking that fucking chick that you
stick of ad they're going to blame
it on you. And then you know what?
You're going to get raped repeatedly
unless you're good at math, you know,
and the warden's a piece of shit and your
shiny shoes or whatever the fuck that
plays out. I don't know. I don't
know. Look, all I know is this.
I got a special coming out August
31st called, why do I do this?
Please do me a favor. Tell
as many people as you know,
and even people you don't know, just
bug people. Just tell them to watch.
It's August 31st my cds
coming out this week,
August 31st comedy central, and then, uh,
my DVD comes out in September. I don't
know why it's happening like this,
but that's the way it's happening. So, um,
please watch that and then come out
and see me cause I've already written a
whole new hour cause cause I'm the
shit. They don't, that's what I,
not the shit. You know who's
getting killed. I'm fucking,
I'm on my way to be in the shit.
Trying to be the shit. All right.
That's why we're not, that's the
real reason why wrote another hour.
Actually that's not the real reason.
The real reason why I wrote this,
cause I'm so fucking paranoid once my
materially has been out there that,
you know, that's a big nightmare.
My being on stage telling a joke
and having the whole proud going,
you already do do on TV. What the fuck?
And then I just started
bombing and then somehow
it spreads across the Internet. No
one ever goes to my shows again.
I got to move back in with
my parents. Then again,
I'm working in a warehouse again on
loading trucks. You know what I mean?
Catastrophizing, I believe
is the thought process. Um,
okay, I'm going to wrap this thing up.
I'm going to be at the comedy works.
These are the gigs in August, and we'll
get the comedy works in, uh, Denver,
Colorado, uh, starting this Thursday.
I think that's July 31st through,
uh, Saturday night, August 2nd.
And uh, go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com to
get all the information.
I'll be at the Miami improv
somewhere around August 12th.
I don't have the fucking
dates in front of me there.
They're sitting right there in the
mind space page. You can say it.
And then after that, I believe I'm doing,
I'm doing the stress factory in
New Jersey, New Jersey. Sorry,
I got the hiccups now. Um, I'm trying
to think if I can remember anymore.
Podcast questions. Somebody asked me
a great question. I didn't drop it,
but it was a copy and paste it
where I can read it right now.
What the fuck was that?
It had something to do.
What is the most overrated thing you ever
saw in your life and what do you think
is the most underrated? And uh, that's,
that's too big a topic to
just come up with one answer.
I'm going to answer even
more of it next week.
But the shit off the top of my head that
I could say was the most overrated shit
of all time. Uh, let's see,
Josh Hartnett the strokes.
Tony Manda rich, any old sports
fans out there? Remember that guy?
The incredible bulk scat
was an offensive line.
They put them on the cover
of sports illustrated.
I Dunno what they thought he was going
to fucking do, but a, he didn't do it.
Uh, what else was overrated? Fame.
Not, not being famous.
Just that TV show fame.
Everybody seems to love that show.
Bruce Springsteen. I don't get it.
I don't fucking get it.
You know the guy sells that giant
stadium 19 times in a row. So a,
it's gotta be me, but I'll tell
ya, I don't, I don't get it.
I don't, I don't fucking get it.
So I guess that's not underrated.
That would be one. How about this? A
good, here's a good one for you guys.
Why don't you guys answer me this one.
What's the most popular thing that
everybody was into that you didn't get?
Okay. Yeah, I'm not, I'm not trashing
Bruce Springsteen like he's fucking,
you know, in sync or a boy band. You
know what I mean? I'm talking about like,
like you know those fucking plastic.
See through clogs that everybody
seems to be wearing now. Crops,
you know, I don't get it.
The only person who wears shoes like
that is stuck in Mario Battalion. Okay.
And I'll let you can make
pasta through the well method.
You shouldn't be wearing
those pocket things. Okay?
I didn't care if you were
on hell's kitchen. Just the
worst fucking show on TV.
Just can't believe it. What else?
People sit there and they
let that guy yell at him.
It's bad enough you've got to go.
Yes, chef. You know what I'm saying?
Like he won a war or something.
Fucking guy makes tuna tar tar.
Get over yourself.
I W I haven't had a child who just
allowed themselves to be yelled at by a
fucking chef to that level. That guy
looks like an Inchcape. Bobby Kelly.
I know Bobby Kelly's losing weight. You
guys should go encourage him by the way.
Look Great. Last time I saw him. This,
I'm looking at the after picture of Bobby
Kelly walking by that he will get to
because I have faith in them. Um,
what else the fuck was I
talking about? Oh yeah.
The shit that everybody's into
that, that I just, I just don't
let them get, you know,
I'll tell you something that's
really fucking underrated. Water
water's really underrated.
Water's one of the most
underrated things of all time.
There is no reason for coke, soda,
these fucking sports strengths.
See electoral lights and all that
shit. They did. Districts the water.
I'll tell you what else is underrated.
If you eat a banana and apple and an
orange and then later on the day you just
have a house salad, you will be as
regular as a fucking race horse.
How these stupid shows on commercials.
What does it take? Giving people pills,
at least fucking old people, you
know, bottles down working anymore.
It's like if they would just eat
some fruit, you know what I mean?
Eat some fruit and then have a fucking
salad and I'm telling you moon river,
any fletch fans out there? Um,
what else? What else was fucking
a, I'll tell you know what?
I'll tell you the one thing that ever
lived, lived up to the hype was the iPod.
The iPod is one of the few
things, you know what I'm saying?
They never lived up to the
heights. And speaking of hype,
I'm going to see Batman this
week. And uh, as far as I know,
he's Leger lives up to the hype
plan. Uh, playing the joker.
I tell it was fucked up.
Somebody had the amount of people who
came up to me with theories as to why he,
oh, cause people thought he killed himself
rather than he sort of took the wrong
stuff the wrong time. You know what
I mean? Rung them out. You know,
somebody told me, he goes, you know,
like, you know what? I know why.
I know why. I don't know why. I
know why he killed himself. He was,
he was losing his hair.
Can you fucking believe that is
one of the dumbest still, like,
like he couldn't affair
of, like, he couldn't,
he couldn't afford a fucking hair plugs.
I'll get one of those. John Travolta
wigs. You don't want to saying,
we'll just shave you fucking head. Take
a nod from me. You know what I mean?
Why would you kill yourself? Just
get it. You know, I just, I don't,
I don't buy that the guy didn't kill
himself. He just, unfortunately,
I don't know what
happened. I haven't like,
I'm going to try to act like I'm
trapper John and d here, you know,
which I'm not obviously haven't
even played a doctor on TV, have I?
No, I haven't. I like it. I like how
it only took me eight seconds to,
to run mentally through my
whole fucking acting career. Um,
so anyways, what time is it
here? Oh, Shit. All right,
my plane's going to be born here in
a few minutes. Um, once again, uh,
thanks to everybody who came
out to my shows in Pittsburgh,
please everybody watch my
special on August 31st called,
why do I do this on comedy central? Uh,
my CD comes out this week, I
believe on August 4th or fifth.
Uh, try to find that in stores. And, um,
you guys really seem to be liking these
random videos that I've been making. Uh,
I just been kinda taping every
set that I do and if, uh,
if I'm basically is what
I'm going to do is if I buy,
just go off on a risk that's kind of
specific to that city or if I have a good
back and forth with somebody.
It's a great way to give you guys some
new laughs without me having to burn any
material. You know what I'm saying?
Yo. You know what I'm saying? Um,
all right. That's it. You
guys all have a good week.
Thanks for listening
to my podcast and, uh,
I'm working on a new website and I will
be putting all of my blogs up there.
Okay. That's why I haven't blogged
in a while. I haven't been blogging,
but I have not posted
any of them because, uh,
evidently the Facebooks,
the myspace and the friend stirs
they own anything you post up there,
they own, like, I can still
make a book of my blogs,
which is what I'd like to do.
But so can they, and a, you know,
I don't like working for free.
I don't know about you guys,
but I don't like doing that. So you know,
I'm just going to start the whale blog
on my space from here on out is I will
just put something, you know, hey,
I wrote a blog and then I'll
just put a link to my website.
That's how I'm going to do with,
because uh, yeah, you know,
I'm saying I'm blogging, blogging from
me. I'm blogging and make you guys laugh.
I'm not blogging to get the fucking
Rupert Murdoch's and more free content.
All right. And that is it. You
guys all have a good week and uh,
I will talk to you later. Please go
out and buy my CD and stores this week.
I believe it's August 4th. I really
wish I had a date. I don't fucking know.
August 4th to August 5th. Just look
forward. Why do I do this in stores?
Tell me what you think and I keep those
podcast questions coming and let me
know. Let me know some of the shit that
you think is overrated or you think is
underrated. And the
one thing that I dunno,
people are just totally
fucking into when you're not,
which might be the same thing as saying
something's overrated. I don't know.
There you go. Why don't you
send me the definition of overrated
too. All right. Have a good week.
But I was sure this
siren sang this song home
dance above the, as I sink, I
see them through a crystal. Hey,
if you're there, a sweet sound
bouncing around the never ending call
the crystal bouncing room
or now once
around the room.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].